Hello everybody, this is Dr. Kevin Conner's welcome to another episode of Conner's
clinic live. Today we have a very special guest friend of mine that has I've known for years,
practices out in the Carolinas, Dr. Akiba Green, Dr. Akiba and I met at some functional medicine
conferences that both he and I were speaking at but we're going to talk about some getting to the
cause of disease and the difference in regular medicine practice and functional medicine practice.
I think you're going to like this interview with Dr. Akiba. He's a great guy.
He has a great practice and remember I hope you enjoy this interview. If always make sure you
don't forget to hit that like button. It helps us and if you're on YouTube make sure you subscribe
and hit that little alarm notification so that if you want to catch our further episodes you'll
be notified when those come up. So thanks so much and let's join Dr. Green.
Well, hello everybody. This is Dr. Kevin Conner's again I'm here with Dr. Akiba Green who's
met a friend of mine for a very long time way back in days when we were just learning functional
medicine, right? And learning to help take care of people at a deeper level. You've done some of
the same fellowships that I've done. You really practice as a natural medicine practitioner,
functional medicine. We're going to talk about that a little bit. You have a fellowship in
integrative cancer therapy, fellowship certification through the American Board of Anti-Aged Health
Professionals and certified in a functional medicine practitioner. Let's jump into that right away
Dr. Green and tell me you know what is a functional medicine practitioner versus a regular medicine
practitioner or chiropractor or naturopath or what would you describe that?
I would tend to say that a functional medicine practitioner is going to be a provider who
is going to look first and foremost at the whole picture. It's going to involve understanding the
origins of the prevention and the treatments of a patient's chronic disease. And I think having
training as a functional medicine practitioner allows us to address the true underlying causes
of the disease. But using a, I like to say, a systems oriented approach. We can engage the patient
actively. We work together with them. We have access to more diagnostic tools than a lot of the
traditional providers do better lab testing. A lot of times we go into other tools that we bring
to our toolbox that may encompass Chinese medicine or energy medicine or other healing arts. And
the whole goal is to be able to find those root causes that a patient's dealing with and be able
to work to effectively treat the patient and get them therapeutically where they want to be.
I've talked to a lot of practitioners that would call themselves functional medicine practitioners.
They all seem to have the same drive to get to some root causes to try to help the patient without
covering up the symptoms. What brought you down this slide? What was your desire at this?
Yeah, I mean, I think if we really go back when we think, you know, I started off
when I was young, went to the chiropractor my whole life. My parents were very into alternative care.
I grew up vegetarian. Eventually went to chiropractic college myself, started treating patients,
saying, realized that patients weren't getting better. There were so many people who were continuing
to suffer. And the one day I realized I had to do more. I had to be able to figure out a better path.
And I started going back to school. And I started on a journey that probably dates back 12 years or
so for me. And it has been an ongoing journey of advanced training, more training. What can we do to
help our patients better accomplish the goals they're looking for? And again, a lot of times it's
learning techniques. Other times it can be an issue of being able to have a deeper understanding
of one condition or another condition or a new approach towards treating. There's things that I do
that are definitely untraditional. My patients have to let me step outside of the box. And I will step
as far outside of the box as I need to if I'm going to get results with the patients. And that's
what it's all driven by is how do we get patients better at the level that they're really looking for?
You know, that brings up a memory of mine. I've ever
going through my integrative cancer fellowship, I don't know, 10 years ago or so
through American Academy of Antagena Medicine, the same one that you got your fellowship through. And I
remember seeing at this round table with about 10 other practitioners that were going through
the fellowship at the time. And they said, oh, let's introduce each other. And they're all like
pediatrician, you know, anesthesiologist. I take a crap here. I'm a choir proctor, you know.
And gets around, I happen to be the last person. And they all have these wonderful resumes that
they were sharing where they work at John Hopkins and this major medical center and such.
And got to be in here. I'm a chiropractor and private practice thinking that I'd get kind of
poo pooed by them. And honestly, I was shocked because they're like, oh my gosh, I want to come
work with you. I had four people at that table literally come up to me and to say, can I someday come
work with you? And I asked them when they were giving me these superlatives about, they're so happy
about my choice and profession. I thought initially, I thought they were joking and then I realized
they weren't joking. They were dead serious. And I literally said, why are you guys so excited about
maybe lowly chiropractor and private practice? And what shocked me, they said, because we can't do
anything that we're learning here in practice. And that was, you know, I never realized I used to
kind of bash the medical profession and rightfully so maybe sometimes. But I never realized that they,
you know, they claim to me that they have the first time I ever heard that term was they had the
golden handcuffs. They can't use natural, they can't take outside the box like you said, you want to
go outside the box as far as possible and help this person. They can learn all these things that I
was learning that I asked them, why are you here? And they were there for the CE credits and to help
their families. So they couldn't even practice, they couldn't even recommend fish oil in their practice
or they're, you know, at the verge of getting fired by the medical, you know, chief of their clinic.
So it is difficult for a regular medical doctor to think outside the box unless they have their
own little private practice, which there's very few of them since they're so tied to insurance about
to state guidelines and what they can do. So if you talk about thinking outside the box, what's your
thought? A reason why people are getting sicker and sicker today despite these phenomenal advances
in the practice of medicine and new drugs coming out. What's your thought process?
Well, I think it starts with the concept that most cases are really not properly diagnosed. So you
have diseases that progress farther and farther and farther. I mean, you can take thyroid management,
for example, they'll run a test called a TSH and it will show normal for years.
Before they finally see that something shifts off and they run a second test or take cancer,
you'll have a mammogram every year and how big does that tumor have to be before it shows up on the
mammogram. It could be months or years before they finally catch it. So what we know is that the
traditional diagnostic tools that are used to find disease don't find it in time and so people get
sicker and sicker. In fact, I mean, you know, we know at cancer treatment, what is it? Over the past
50 years, I think I studied that a red a few years ago, said that cancer survival rates overall had
improved approximately two months. Yeah. I mean, that's unacceptable. When you have that level of care,
it's probably just because they're getting diagnosed two months earlier too. I'll probably
write on that as well. And listen, I'm not going to say that there are not advances in medicine. I'm
not going to say that there are not new tools. I think the concept of immunotherapy is something that
excites me with checkpoint inhibitors and it's something that I've read so much about. But you know,
the key concept is it's still looking at an approach of being reactive and trying to go against the
body versus trying to figure out how to help support the body. You know, now if we look elsewhere,
the US, how much do we use the world's pharmaceuticals? 50%. We spend more on healthcare than almost
what 10 other countries and yet people don't get better. They continue to suffer. So we treat our
patients and they're not getting better. Why? Because the system that we're using is broke.
You know, they go and when the whole Affordable Care Act came out and you said more people are going to
get access to healthcare, that's great. But the healthcare itself doesn't change. So we're not going to
see improvements in our patient model. Yeah. Yeah. It's kind of a broken system. There really isn't
any solution except a grassroots solution really. Yeah. That people start taking responsibility
themselves not giving over their power just to their doctor and keep digging themselves and not wanting
to just take a simple diagnosis and cover it up their symptoms with the medication. So you know,
you see people go to the doctor and you know, the question is that everybody has why don't I feel
better after I've taken this medication? Well, we're taught from an early age. You go to your doctor
when you're sick and in our doctor knows best and they're going to get as well. The problem is they
are not trained in helping fix the types of chronic health problems that we're seeing in our country.
I mean, the standard of care has to be followed. You come in, you have a symptom. They say,
let me look at the algorithm that I've been trained on. Let me look at the algorithm that my hospital
system allows me to use. And then you have to fit into that mold in order to have a treatment.
And they step outside of that. I mean, it wasn't until the early 2000s that the state of North Carolina
allowed medical providers to give you a treatment that was outside of the standard of care without
risk of losing their license. That's crazy. In many states, I know that that is a risk. I think
that's some issues, you know, up in the North or maybe Midwest where you are where doctors can't do
everything they want to. It really is that except that handcuff. But so what do we do? We have patients
that say, hey, let me go to the doctor. I'm going to get treated. The doctor runs a lab test
and says a lab test is normal. I'll see you in six months. And nothing is done because they're only
running that one lab test. They're only running a small little screening test instead of actually
digging in deeper to find out where the problems are coming from. And patients are told the wrong
thing. They're told there's nothing wrong with you or you're normal. Instead of being told,
this one test that I ran came back normal. And I can't do anything about it because that's all I've
got. Patients seem to be given the opportunity to say, this doctor hasn't gone deep enough. Let me
find somebody who has. Yeah, and they get lab lessons if they do. So you practice in North Carolina.
That's, you've always practiced there. Is that correct? That's right. In a town called Cornelius
area called Lake Norman. Tell us a little bit about where you are, your practice. Let us know
what your website is, too. So people are going to be interested there. So we're in a northern suburb
of Charlotte. We've got a beautiful lake that's over 500 square miles. It's not as big as a great lake,
stuff like you, but it is a beautiful lake. And it's a real great atmosphere for people. People
love to live there, but in my practice, we see patients that come in typically from a two to four-hour
around each way drive. And so we draw from multiple states, West Virginia, Virginia, South
Carolina and North Carolina. And we also see a lot of patients virtually from all over the country
or really the Western Hemisphere. Our emphasis in our clinic is functional medicine. We also do
a good bit of brain-based therapies for patients who are able to commute to our clinic. I use several
advanced tools in my office, something called neurofeedback therapy, a treatment called Pulse
Electromagnetic Field Therapy or PPMF therapy, as well as RIF therapy. I just named a few of them.
And the whole goal is how can we treat our patients? How can we fix the damage that's been done to
their body? While we use functional medicine, lab testing, Chinese medicine to figure out why the
damage occurred and get those root causes corrected. So if I was a patient and I was, you know,
struggling with, let's say fatigue and I thought I had thyroid issues and I went to my doctor and
he did a TSH. And, you know, it's been kind of normal and maybe he suggested, you know, some
medication. But how would that my visit with you look differently if I came to you?
The first thing we're going to do is we're going to do a really good case review. And so many of
answers with, for example, with thyroid patients are going to start with an issue of looking at
where their symptoms actually are. So you're on medication, you're on scintoroid or armor or whatever
they put you on and you still have fatigue, you still have sleep issues, you still have depression,
you still have all these symptoms. And so obviously, something's being missed. They're not where we need
to be. So we dig in deep, we help to identify what types of lab tests can help us get those answers
we're missing. We usually do a neurological examination as well as identifying and looking at the thyroid
itself. And we try to come up with an understanding of what's wrong with your body. We then really put
together a blueprint for, how do we find the reason why you're not getting the results you're looking for
with your medication? Sometimes you stay on your medication because you don't have the ability
to produce hormone anymore if there is damage. Other times, we work with your doctors to change
your medication to something that's better. But it's all about, you know, let's start with the understanding
of where do we have to get answers? Let's get those answers and start getting tests. We talk dietary
modification. We talk tools in our toolbox, which includes supplementation. And again, we go really deep
to be able to say, let's fix what we found wrong so we can not only make changes, but let's also track
and really make sure we're seeing those changes that the patients are looking for instead of just
saying, I'll see you in six months. Yeah, it's exciting when you see people that have struggled
finding answers for many times years that start to turn their life around and start to see results.
I'm sure you have hundreds of cases like that. That's what's satisfied and continue to drive what
you do. Let's unplug your website again and your clinic again. So the clinic name actually
Lake Norman Health and Wellness has been my clinic for 17 years, but we have rebranded over the
past year to Lake Norman Integrative Wellness as we expand our services. Our website is still the same.
It's at www.drakibagr.com. Our website also holds my blog. We also have a really robust social media
presence on Instagram and Facebook. It's at www.drakibagr.com and it's a great resource to learn about
our clinic, to see patient testimonials and reviews. We always do different webinars and workshops
that we post live. You can also get information about becoming a patient whether you are in the Charlotte
North Carolina area or across the country. I'd love to have you out again and talk about some other
things that I know that you're doing. I'd really like to talk to you about neurofeedback because that's a
big interest in people's lives right now. Just have a whole show just on neurofeedback and some of
the results that you're seeing too. And some of the cancer work you're doing and the work with
with rife. So I'd love to bring you back on if you're interested. Thank you for coming on. You've
been a friend of mine for a long time. Dr Akima Greed in North Carolina and we will share on the website
at the end of this as well. Thank you Dr. Greed. Thank you for having me. It was fun. Bye bye.